Kim and I just got into the biggest
fight she just was going so crazy she's
sending me the meanest text messages you
would die
well Kim and Kourtney Kardashian are at
it again she's like you're the biggest
ungrateful son I said god you're such a
petty woman and she's like is that a
joke I had to intervene when your
stylist hold the nastiest clothes for
you for your birthday
oh good yeah you heard that this all
comes down to clothing basically that's
the biggest fight with Kourtney today
because she just is such a much like on
another level so I called Kourtney and
Kourtney's like screamed at me on the
phone you and was like you think I like
your style you have the lamest style
this all goes down in a sneak peak of
Sunday's new episode of Keeping Up with
the Kardashians and it doesn't stop
there I said you're going just cool to
become a lawyer and help the world and
these are the kinds of problems you have
and she's that you're really a miserable
human being and you keep not
understanding the issue because you all
of a sudden turn into such a
humanitarian and talk about the world's
issues which you've not contributed one
ounce to the world damn but that was
actually nothing compared to what Kim
said next you can fake humanitarian ho I
actually do [ __ ] for the world
you can fake it all day long and act
like oh there's people dying can and
what the hell are you doing about it
oh snap Kim really was there of course
this is not the first time Kim and
Kourtney have feuded in another recent
clip that you are even fighting about
style again she doesn't care about you
and I yeah I don't know what you're
talking about I've never dressed like
you Oh is there a fight no if I'm being
honest this all seems a little petty
especially since Kim recently had a
health scare illness in my bones I
probably stay positive until he gets
results et was just with Kim where she
opened up even more about her health it
was really hard cuz I couldn't pick up
the kids for a while because I had a lot
of pain in my hands so until I figured
it out of what was really going on I
really needed to just like take a break
from lifting the baby and that was
really hard for me my baby Chicago who's
like a big baby you know she's not light
but I was really worried that I had my
baby coming my baby boy and I just
thought it was gonna be really hard for
me so luckily I got it all under wraps
but when you do have a diagnosis or you
get tested for something and you get a
result that you weren't expecting you
definitely get in your head and you
start for a second you kind of get this
little depression of okay what are all
the possibilities that can happen what's
my life gonna look like I really want to
be active for my kids and so it triggers
something but then I really had to get
myself together we're always sending Kim
and Kourtney the best for all the latest
on the Kardashians keep stickin with et
until next time I'm Katie Krauss and bye
for now
you